ces images ont été tournées il ya
quelques jours la vidéo d'un ours de
cirque en russie qui en pleine
représentation devant le public s'en est
pris à son dresseur une vidéo qui a
énormément choqué le public et les
spectateurs présents sur place si le
circo s'est voulu rassurant sur l'état
de santé du dresseur les responsables de
l'établissement ont tout de suite accusé
les spectateurs d'avoir agité l'animal
en prenant des photos avec le flash
si les organisateurs semblent vouloir se
dédouaner très rapidement c'est parce
qu'ils sentent la polémique gronde et
sur les réseaux sociaux nombreux sont
ceux qui ont utilisé cet accident pour
remettre en question ce type de
spectacle des images qui relance
fortement le débat tendu sur la place
des animaux dans les cirques des débats
qui avaient déjà fait rage autour du cas
de l'éléphant maya ou encore de
l'hippopotame jumbo les hippopotames
dans la nature ils passent leur vie dans
la rivière jumbo lui il est tout seul
sans eau
si certains directeurs de cirque ont
décidé de prendre des mesures et de
retirer de leurs spectacles tous les
numéros impliquant des animaux sauvages
pour d'autres il n'est pas question de
gâcher la fête pour eux les animaux
sauvages sont dressés depuis des
décennies pour apparaître dans des
spectacles et il n'y a pas de raison que
ça change
il assure que les bêtes sont bien
traitées et qu'elles sont heureuses si
ces spectacles sont toujours populaires
en france le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que le sujet divise
d'après un récent sondage deux tiers des
français seraient opposés à
l'exploitation d'animaux sauvages dans
les cirques
alors d'après vous faut-il interdire les
animaux dans les cirques
alors la question où vous la poser et je
peux vous dire que ça réagit énormément
alors pour vous valérie bernis oui il
faut les interdire voulait qu'on va
revoir voir des vidéos dans un instant
savoir sur le sujet qui sont
complètement folle mais pour vous oui il
faut interdire je ne mets pas en doute
l'amour que les propriétaires d'animaux
sauvages dans les cirques ont pour leurs
animaux je ne mets pas en doute le fait
qu'ils lui mais qu'ils fassent tout leur
possible éventuellement pour qu'il soit
le mieux possible mais la place d'un
animal sauvage c'est justement dans la
nature c'est pas dans un cirque
si on le demande et je pense qu'on
demandera notre invité combien de mètres
carrés on les cages même si ils essaient
d'avoir la plus grande cage possible
même si c'est sec 2 de rendre ces
animaux les plus heureux du monde
ils seront de toute façon moins bien
lotis que dans leur espace naturel
donc voilà il n'y a pas d'intérêt
aujourd'hui le cirque doit évoluer avec
la société on a évolué et nous avec
notre position sur le monde animal
le cirque doit évoluer également est par
ailleurs il ya de très très jolie cirque
maintenant il ya le cirque du soleil par
exemple y arrive après l'irlande sur les
moyens on peut très bien faire les
jongleurs c'est le cirque les clous et
c'est le cirque les acrobates c'est le 6
mai mais on n'est pas obligé d'avoir des
animaux sauvages alors sur le plateau de
morandini life chez jean-marc sur ses
news il ya andré joseph bouglione
voilà du nom du célèbre cirque qui a
annoncé qu'il allait arrêter les animaux
dans son cirque et il explique pourquoi
regarder mon discours ce n'est de dire
qu'aujourd'hui le public ne veut plus
revoir d'animaux sauvages dans les
cirques afin d' animaux tôt comme moi
c'est ce que je pense la meilleure
solution c'est de renoncer à la
présentation d'animaux il ya beaucoup de
gens dans les cirques ils ne comprennent
pas qu'il faut arrêter avec les animaux
totalement en même temps les sondages
sont tous unanimes
est ce que les animaux dans les cirques
sont maltraités c'est parce que je dis
non mais bon c'est la question que vous
pouviez nombre moi ce que je dis c'est
qu'on peut pas généraliser et a
évidemment des établissements où les
animaux sont pas maltraitées et des
établissements où ils le sont sauf que
ça dure depuis très longtemps et à un
moment donné il faut faire le ménage
dans la profession alors il ya frédéric
edelstein qui nous a rejoint accompagner
on a peur pour alors vous êtes des
dresseurs de pauvres depuis de forme
depuis 35 ans directeur du cirque pinder
vous êtes offre le frère et je suis
voilà je suis le frère de sophie qui
continue ses tournées ces grandes
illusions un petit peu de partout en
alors pourquoi vous êtes contre l'arrêt
voilà des animaux sauvages valeurs
écoute et je suis triste de devoir
prouver ma bonne foi
à chaque émission à chaque lieu où je me
produire pour dire que les animaux sont
bien aussi
je suis actuellement dans un petit
établissement puisque vous savez qu'on a
arrêté les tournées avec mon cirque
pinder depuis le mois d'avril l'an
dernier je suis avec le beau cirque
claudio zavatta où il ya à peu près une
soixantaine d'animaux qui m'entourent et
où il ya la présentation de dunes de
numéro de fauves didier prend mon ami
didier prin qui présente neuf lions et
lionnes et moi qui présente mes 12 lions
blancs ce que je veux vous dire par là
c'est que mes deux lions étaient
destinés dans des fermes d'élevage à se
faire shooter pour 15000 dollars pièce
j'ai sauvé ses douze bêtes d'un
véritable massacre croyait pas que vous
pouviez les voir en liberté dans des
grands enclos ou dans des grands espaces
ils sont dans ce qu'on appelle la chasse
en boîte destinée à se faire tirer
dessus pour le business de la chasse
alors oui je pensais qu'un animal
n'avait pas un animal sauvage un million
à tigre un éléphant n'avait pas sa place
comme vous le disiez valérie au cirque
j'arrêterai demain mon métier il ya même
plus dans clos quand vous voyez dans le
petit établissement où je me trouve le
beau cirque claudio zavatta la façon
dont on s'occupe des animaux au
quotidien et les grands espaces les
dromadaires les chameaux qui n'ont pas
besoin d'avoir des oncles aux structures
et puisque ça reste des animaux
domestiques mais qui se baladent de
partout qui vont côtoyer les gens et
c'est le même cas pour l'ens lyon
ils sont certes danser dans des énormes
sanglots frédéric on va on va en parler
de l'instant pas ce qu'on va voir on va
voir les oui on va voir les noms il ya
un cas de maltraitance qui est suspecté
dans un cirque en france et le cadre de
l'ipo potable djombo
selon les associations ce pachyderme n'a
rien à faire dans un cirque
regardez regarde un hippopotame
c'est un animal qui a besoin d'eau les
hippopotames dans la nature ils passent
leur vie dans la rivière la journée et
en plus ce sont des animaux qui sont
très sociaux donc ils ont besoin d'être
en groupe jumbo lui il est tout seul
sans eau depuis trois ans nos enquêteurs
le suivent constamment et on a
chronométré qu' il ne sort du camion que
30 minutes par jour
nous avons tout organiser pour
transférer jumbo en afrique donc il n'y
a pas de raison qu'un circuit est en
infraction continue de l'être
alors alors michel bergue parce que là
on n'est pas du tout dans des bars
d'entendre parler des conditions de vie
des ennemis je dis pas pour elles
traitées qui sont mal nourris que
c'était ça le problème des animaux
n'attire que c'est que c'est pas eux on
les présente pas on a fait faire des
numéros
oui c'est leur cas n'est peut être pas
besoin de faire huit ans d'études pour
se dire que pour qu'un ours monde sur un
ballon avant sur un banal heures à
belfort entend taleb la trop évolué
torture avant pour les faire les numéros
et leur goût les normes laissé répondre
conduire à les y résident
alors j'ai vu la vidéo avec cet ours ou
bien entendu vous avez ce pauvre et
soeurs qui se fait attraper mais c'est
déjà dans les pays de l'est n'a
strictement rien à voir avec les
techniques de dressage qui sont employés
dans notre pays en france
oui mais bon les pays de l'est déjà
reste un pays qui est beaucoup plus dur
si le dresseur et bien évidemment mal
mal à me mauvais ami et maltraite son
animal automatiquement il va se
retourner contre eux - venaient me voir
travailler venez voir mes confrères
travailler dans d'autres pays
les animaux ne sont pas du tout avec de
la maltraitance et vous obtenez que je
me sens avec l'animal te ment doucement
avec un morceau de viande et yoplait
frédéric j'aimerais jouer et montrer une
vidéo caf un scandale à l'étranger on
regarde et on va voir
voilà des dressage d'ours et vous allez
voir ça certains scandales est la risée
un aspect 1,8 à maltraitance contre la
brutale où les conditions même dans les
cirques je suis content regardez
regardez ce n'est pas le cas dans
regarder y garder en 2015 un témoin
s'est rendu à suzhou en chine
une zone qui héberge plus de 300 cirque
cette enquête de péta asie montre les
violences endurées par les animaux
dressés les dresseurs force les bébés à
se tenir sur les pattes arrière avec des
chaînes autour du cou s'il essaie de se
remettre sur leurs quatre pattes
il s'étrangle rond et se pendre ont eux
mêmes la violence et l'intimidation sont
les méthodes du dresseur pour forcer les
oursons à tenir en équilibre sur des
planches balançoire sauter par dessus
les objets ou marcher sur les mains les
ours vivaient dans nos tristes cash
étroite et répugnante
il pleurait et passer leurs pattes entre
les barreaux désespéré
honteuse et honteux je suis le premier à
le dire mais c'est pas dans notre pays
alors elle était lourde comme ça
frédéric je vous montre à coup sûr moi
parce que je leur donne un petit morceau
de viande in fine ml fans émus entier la
peur des sinistres non mais sérieux des
exemples je voudrais bien sûr vous avez
en allemagne mon copain martin lacey
vous avez ou beaussire claudio zavatta
où je me trouve actuellement
bien sûr vous avez dédié présente mois
de l'année 2013 avec tania valérie bien
sûr ont calmé les deux la pratique et
les chéris il ya quelques semaines parce
que j'aurai montre un truc vous dites ça
n'existe pas en france dit une bêtise
ouais amérique voilà l'association one
voice avait dénoncé des conditions de
vie des mères d'un arbre elle sait
exploiter dans des foires et des
spectacles de cirque et ça ça se passe
en france mais ce gars et nous reste à
bien deux jours qu'il faut parvenir à
regarder ça fait pas chier oui c'est bon
il y a cinq notre retour sont france qui
exploite 8 8 ours dont trois qui nous
posent particulièrement problème et les
trois heures s'étaient polyakov et don
mischer qui c'est qui a été donnée en
spectacle dimanche et j'ai de l'arthrose
qu'il fait boiter il a des problèmes
d'usure des griffes qui lui causent des
souffrances aux pattes
theolia com en fait quand ils rentrent
chez eux les ours sont enfermés dans des
cages dans des 10 dès 10h que jamais il
leur donne à manger de la nourriture qui
a varié
c'est vraiment un problème beaucoup plus
important et beaucoup plus urgent que
les autres marqueurs
il a plus de sens oui mais oui mais bon
il est venu travailler en france ça je
suis contre lui mais je sais d'ailleurs
où est ce que l'animal a été remis
puisque ce sont des gens qui l'ont pas
actually dans leurs sanctuaires
ce qu'il faut savoir donc le sanctuaire
où il a été est un bon sanctuaire mais
ce qu'il faut savoir que c'est que ces
soi-disant sanctuaire pour les animaux
qui sont faits pour les animaux on s'est
rendu compte qu'il voulait transformer
ces sanctuaires pour prendre les animaux
des gens de syrte
il est maintenant descendre quatre soit
manceau direction public va venir mais
il faut faire le ménage et kelly le
problème il est là qu elle dit que je
parle je suis pas du tout à l'aise à la
place que j'ai choisi là maintenant mais
parce que j'ai une pensée aussi pour je
sais pas vous allez super seulement
m'insulter mathieu moi j'ai une pensée
pour les familles
pas voyager qui peut pas rencontrer des
animaux donc j'avais vraiment plier des
lois qu'ils soient appliqués qui est des
sanctions qui des vraies choses de
construite qui est que des messieurs
comme vous en france et qu'on puisse
enfin faire découvrir les animaux sont
les ou non
eh bien c'est ce que je vais vous
soucier c'est que dans notre pays il ya
une loque et d'ariane si vous pouvez
surfer très directe ne pouvait pas la
parole quand je vous la donne pas s'il
vous plaît juste qu'elle y est l'été de
ce côté là elle a changé d'avis juste
pour ça voilà mais alors c'est vrai que
au fond d'elle elle est plus du côté de
rationner des animaux mais c'est moi
c'est alors que je vive alors que les
gens moi j'aime les défis auxquels
géraldine maillet alors ma frédéric je
remet absolument pas en cause votre
bienveillance va tout l'amour des
animaux comme la plupart et l'immense
majorité des circassiens pour autant
vous comprenez que moi je suis quand
même dubitatif quand je vois un éléphant
s'asseoir sur un pouf
alors quand mais je suis pas d'accord
d'aller chic dans lequel animal
naturellement 2009 dans la nature on est
d'accord que pas plus donc ça veut dire
qu'il ya une semaine mais tout ce qu'on
appelle il ya une forme d'esclavagisme
enfin il ya une forme d'esclavagisme
frédéric et donc ça c'est très choquant
et peta france dit pardon qu'il ya quand
même des bateaux électrifié qu'on
torture les animaux non non mais ça dans
les pays alors regardez je vous montrer
une autre vidéo c'est le dressage voilà
c'est un message des défauts aussi se
soit arrêtée hausse et dressage de faux
aussi la peta vous allez voir et pour
eux c'est de la maltraitance animale
regarder ça aussi alors je crois que
c'est pas en france
voilà mais bon quand même regarder des
vidéos de moi avec les lions oui oui
vous remonterez j'aimerais bien ces
papillons mon plus jeune âge à craindre
des humains
[Musique]
durant leur dressage les grands félins
qui passait la plupart de leur temps
dans des trois de cages métalliques et
les cellules bétonné été battue et
menacée avec de lourdes bars et des
fouets pour leur faire exécuter des
tours comme sauter a failli remporter et
tenir en équilibre sur des ballons cette
cruauté n'est pas spécifique à la chine
dans le monde entier des animaux sont
dressés à faire certains des fours que
l'on voit dans cette vidéo
la seule façon possible de faire faire à
des animaux sauvages des choses qui
n'ont aucun symptôme qui ne sont pas
naturels voire qui sont terrifiantes
comme ces numéros d'acrobatie c'est de
leur faire du mal et de les menacer
d'encore plus de douleur alors ils
étaient 2000 2003 éric j'aimerais
entendre les hôtes également isabelle je
vous rappelle que j'ai à ce calme
jusqu'à il ya trois quatre ans l'animal
avait un statut d'objet donc c'est tout
un système à mettre en place maintenant
alors les animaux d'investir ça veut
tout dire c'est aussi bien le cacatoès
que l'éléphant donc au nom il faut
interdire certains numéros sont
absolument nettoyer le secteur mais on
peut pas tout interdit parce qu'il ya
des animaux qui ont vraiment un instant
ludique et qui aime jouer avec l'homme
outre vous allez travailler dans un zoo
oui j'ai trouvé dans un zoo et
j'accompagnais pendant trois ans à 21h
le lundi le lundi parce que c'est le
dimanche on donne des cacahuètes aux
animaux qui sont souvent malades dans
les eaux et dans les sirh que le lundi
est donc on allait les soigner le lundi
et j'ai vu effectivement des animaux
certains ont besoin d espace d'autres -
qui était passionnément aimée par leurs
maîtres donc d'y interdire purement et
simplement tout parce que alors qu'il
faut changer la loi
c'est sale c'est pas la même chose voire
rien un chien c'est un animal domestique
et pas de problème mais pourquoi un lion
ou 1 attire soit pas là malgré un
souvenir de héros mais les voix dans la
case oui mais vous vous montrez moi j'ai
un problème c'est que jallet clément
certain qu'un lion s'il n'a pas pris un
coup de bâton avant il va pas monter sur
le nom mais c'est le fini ben non c'est
parce que la preuve si vous êtes
toujours d'un an dans votre main vous ai
toujours une récompense donc le lion ce
qu'est ce qui se dit si je monte des
récompenses qui fout la gamme d'options
c'est impossible autrement jj et plein
de gens parce qu'il faut lui apprend bas
l'amérique aux est alors oui je vous
dise quelque chose quand vous avez un
animal c'est tout simple c'est comme
avec les chiens bahreïn est d'ailleurs
j'emmène mes chiens parce que sk pas de
la maltraitance
quand on laisse son chien son chat
pendant toute une journée dans un
appartement dans une maison
enfermé on va travailler et on le revoit
que le soir non allez on
halloween c'est demain
je vois je suis cyril oui alors le veut
préserver mon métier que j'aime je suis
un dresseur il je suis un dresseur il
faut pas avoir peur de le dire on n'a
jamais fait de mal à un animal quand je
veux obtenir quelque chose avec un lion
j'ai d'abord des bambous dans la main
avec un petit morceau de viande au bout
du bambou et c'est comme ça que je
dirige l'animal là où je le veux
automatiquement il ya une éducation a
créé avec un animal sauvage comme avec
un chien ou avec un chat avec une
croquette pour une récompense pour le
diriger vous n'allez pas lui apprendre
comme ça mais c'est certainement pas en
le maltraitant ans le brutalisant en lui
donnant des coups ou en utilisant de
l'électricité où on le piquant pour le
l'aller dans un cerceau curé déjà eu des
tirs au but
vous avez d'abord une toute petite
flamme quand un humain sautent dans un
cerceau tu es qui se brûlent un lion que
c'est pareil
le seul truc une fois qu'il a compris
que ça lui faisait rien en passant dans
le cerveau de feu il n'a pas peur c'est
pas le numéro qu'on met en tout elle
elle est là la ville valérie bénaïm
apprendre à fabien lecoeuvre kiki
frédéric vous le savez bien
effectivement moi je vous connais je ne
remets vraiment pas en cause je sais à
quel point vous aimez vos animaux mais
vous savez bien que pour un secret
d'eric haldenstein danton toute la
france il ya d'autres gens qui
n'utilisent pas vos méthodes et donc
parce qu'il n'ya pas qu'il n'ya qu'un
vrai dire est qu'elle d'einstein
il faut les gagner faire le ménage dans
secret ça veut dire où le rang des
données ont plongé de légiférer et on
est obligé de prendre des positions un
peu radical parce que de toute façon
vous vous avez sauvé vos animaux qui
étaient destinés à la mort il ya des
animaux qui sont dans des cirques il
n'était pas du tout destinés à la mort y
aurait dû être en pleine nature je vous
montrais le 24 novembre 2010 êtes vous
dit ça des animaux pleine nature c'est
un tigre qui s'est échappé d'un cirque
en plein paris il a été à bacchus avait
fait un énorme scandale regarder il est
18 heures hier quand elle s'échappe de
sa cage mais vit une tigresse de 200 kg
le quartier est aussitôt bouclé
impossible de la faire revenir
la décision est prise elle doit être
abattu la porte est ouverte
je n'explique pas ça fait ça fait ça
fait 40 ans de chats paris ça fait 50
ans j'ai jamais eu l'ombre d'un point
avec les tigres ou et me tuer sa
tigresse
c'était la seule solution il n'avait pas
le temps de l'anesthésié voilà alors ça
ça a énormément parlé fait venir le cas
moi je pense qu'on a changé d'époque
il faut admettre cerner en 2020 oui mais
la tâche et je lui dois filer si finir
les gens je pense qu'en 1920 les cirques
avait un rôle très intéressant parce que
les populations dernier et revient
n'avait jamais vu vraiment d'animaux
dont convenait voir des animaux etc dans
des cirques voilà aujourd'hui à départ
comme beauval comme thoiry et c'est ce
qu'on vient voir des animaux aujourd'hui
avec avec les écrans la télé avec
internet on peut voir tous les animaux
de la terre en gros plan
donc aujourd'hui le rôle n'est plus le
même et je pense que la conscience
aujourd'hui la société c'est de
comprendre qu'on est en 2020 il s'est
passé 100 ans on en 2020 la 65 jours
pour verser ouais c'est bon et en fait
donc au delà tout je pense que la
considération
moi je moi je suis militant pour
inscrire un secrétariat d'état à
l'animal parce qu'il ya longtemps qu on
devrait déjà engagé ce que tu es un
recteur est vrai défenseur de la cause
la mer dans le jeu comprend très bien
mais je pense qu'ils fonctionnent tous
de la même manière aujourd'hui les
enfants vu des animaux à la télé sur
internet
on n'a plus besoin d'aller dans un
cirque alors ce que le cirque a eu un
rôle très important mais je pense qu'il
doit évoluer avec son époque
alors michael binger consolidation ma
vie parce que j'ai agacé parce que les
lier et les gentils et l'ailleurs et les
méchants ça marche pas comme ça la vie
pardon cyril les images que vous avez
passé sont horribles mais c'est comme si
on passait des images d'enfants frappés
que derrière les haies ne plus jamais
faire d'enfant non ce sont des
exceptions qui sont horribles
effectivement pardon j'ai un peu
travaillé dessus j'ai très souvent
qu'ils sont pas en france
en général ils sont éduqués
effectivement avec de la récompense
comme on peut éduquer un enfant avec une
punition ou une récompense quand elles
sont peu d'une image un animal à l'effet
ne fonctionne qu'avec de l'amour avec de
l'amour tu le sais tu un chien et on dit
toujours voilà seul le chien pour pour
son être son sofa sont sombres
m pardon c'est tout les animaux avaient
vivent à l'amour aussi
il ya des générations entre
hier de cirque qui ont des animaux
compte toujours été bien traité qui la
zone selon lui ce que leurs propres
conclusions sur ce qu'il faut faire le
ménage absolument non mais c'est pas
parce qu'à quelques personnes tard est
arrivée d'autres pays et que du coup on
manque de police pour ces personnes là
qu'il faut punir tous ceux qui aiment le
sur thur les gens qui aiment leur métier
aiment leur domaine
sombre et amoureux d'or l'heure normale
wittig rapport à porter une cage avec un
tigre en inde où la cage là restera un
cas je vais à se barrer mais ça n'a rien
à voir
le michel tu dis ça n'a rien à voir
s'ils restent des tigres jean michel
c'est aussi parce que des cristaux nord
est où descendent l'occupant mais s'en
occupe et je termine que la culture est
ce que tu es bac tu crois que ces
animaux qui sont dans un cirque
en fait il serait sinon dans l'avenir la
dent dans la brousse je ne marche pas
comme ça la vie
mais non il ya beaucoup de nouveaux qui
sont en captivité juste aventure ils
sont nés qui sont nés en captivité qui
sont aimés comme ça qu'ils sont protégés
aussi parfois grâce à les eaux grâce à
des autres et c'est ce monsieur est donc
pas dû m'en vouloir mc animaux les
formules vous aider les jeunes des
enfants gilbert la conclusion sampdoria
est formidable des conclusions de ça
c'est qu'il faut faire le ménage et
arrêter de penser que nous donne ce côté
là quand on voit ces images on n'est pas
des machines
on est au rythme des images à chaque
fois de ces associations qui vont
tourner des images dans les pays de
l'est ou dans des pays qui se ferme et
qu'on passe mes images avec mais lyon
convoi et comment sont les conditions de
rites et je vous assure que toutes les
nouvelles générations des jambes cirque
et même des petits établissements et des
petits cirques à l'heure actuelle les
animaux sont bien une chose toute simple
comment est ce que vous pensez que je
peux obtenir quelque chose avec mes deux
petits chiens qui régente qui manquent
comme ça avec ce qu'il ya de l'amour
hier la publicité ils ont une récompense
à chaque fois et si resort dont ils
pensent maintenant parce qu'ils le
savent et moi j'amène mes chiens avec
moi parce que y'a rien de plus horrible
pour un toutou c'est d'attendre son
maître pendant une journée entière sur
et qu ils ne le voient pas moi un
restaurant un hôtel un établissement
vacances me refuse mes chiens lme les
refusent je ne serais pas venu je me
sens même mes chiens avec moi pastiche
content d'être avec nous bien sûr pg et
je n'ai pas honte je suis fier des
déménageurs et c'est pour ça que je suis
comme ça que j'ai rencontré
quand la frappe j'avais série pourquoi
est-ce qu'il faut toujours non payent
pour les joies des rayons cyril demander
si on ne les ai pas ces vidéos si vous
demandez qui ne les ont pas ils les ont
pas ils étaient petits quand tu étais
petit tu allais au tu aller au cirque tu
adores et a trouvé ça mignon pourquoi
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on priverait toute
cette nouvelle génération ce qui
continue que le monde a changé
mais il a changé à kohat gones de
quelques personnes non effectivement
font mal leur travail cela ils voulaient
sanctionner
en revanche il faut continuer d'aimer
les gens qui aiment leur travail c'est
avec amour pardon yom son néon cirque
claudio zavatta ya une semaine à
chemillé way ne trouve avec ce cirque
c'est juste à côté de cholet
j'ai fait une vidéo avec les petits
pieds on les a pas rêvé avec vos vies
des manifs ici si les animaux étaient
mal au cirque mais j'avais tout
frederiction ray derrière jamais même
jour et d'eric on n'en peut plus la
comète non mais jeudi on n'en peut plus
beaucoup mais tu m'as sous les coutumes
azul et c'était de crise qui va choquer
à nordouz non mais pas du match ok mais
non mais ça défend on parle de lyon de
tig d'éléphants du vote m ça n'a rien à
faire dans un centre et non c'est toi
ici c'est ici ça soit bien sûr mais un
tigre à lyon oui food en inde dans un
cirque benjamin tu avais acheté
inquiéter gros comme ça quand je t'ai
connu qui était énorme mais j'aurais
aimé qu'ils avaient chaud qui était fait
pour nager twitter dans un appartement
toute la journée c'était sa place mais
il l a compris que ce sera mieux arrêter
conneries ce n'était pas sa place
frédéric laisser parler les gens
sincères ya deux façons de voir si un
animal est ce qu'on appelle nous heureux
c'est dire s'il est adapté s'il se
reproduit un animal né en captivité qui
sont reproduites un animal qui est bien
adapté dans son mini dures il n'est pas
heureux quand on met au rose est une
notion humaine mais dans la neige et
dans la nature arrêtons de fantasmer la
nature entre les pesticides le
braconnage l'extension des terres
agricoles
on offre émane en français le problème
est complexe
thème le radicaliser la scion isabelle
ou un autre jean michel a dit faites une
phrase complète maladies les pesticides
on parle de lyon la savane ya pas qu on
sera à l'origine des gens mais je
t'adore mais c'est caricatural à
l'époque a dit fabien lecoeuvre
non non attendez plus le dax bat
frédéric je pense que vous vous changer
de sujet c'est pas l'amour c'est pas la
considération des cirques l'accord le
public vous ne parlez jamais du public
le public a changé est ce que là il va
recommencer par la chose quelques temps
c'est ça qu'est ce que tu as pu
s'arrêter sur une info que tu n'as pas
bien le cas on se calme
battus et de leurs moyens alors je
voulais vous montrer une vidéo mois
d'une association juste avant qu'on
continue et oui on affronte m'agace
c'est l'un des symboles du combat entre
associés aux lycées minorité de halle
est âgé de 49 ans il aura fallu
plusieurs années de bataille judiciaire
pour que maya ne fasse plus de numéros
de cirque
regardez nous sommes revenus aujourd'hui
aux mayas dans la rue mais l'âme sommes
venus près d'elle
puisqu'on ne sait pas où elle va aller
la semaine prochaine c'est pas si elle
va être dans les quatre quartiers
d'hiver coincé dans son camion à mourir
ou alors encore en piste
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'elle a mal c'est
qu'elle souffre nous aimerions que les
experts des éléphants et des éléphants
d'asie qui plus est soit entendu par
padash est oui alors prairies ou qu'ils
aient 35 ans en arrière
j'entendais le même discours on me
disait que c'était fini les animaux
aussi requis que c'était la mort du cir
est la fin du cirque c'était
l'apparition de la télévision il y avait
des trucs un peu de choses il faisait
que c'était complètement différent et
tout le monde disait que c'était terminé
c'est une mode ces associations sont une
minorité qui ne sont virulents que via
les réseaux sociaux
il ya un permettre via des sociétés de
looping mais ces gens ne représentent en
rien je vois tous les jours au cirque
l'audio vidéo
[Applaudissements]
pour lui bref merci la gauche c'est vrai
qu'il est ce que tu ta tête et est à
fond ah ouais il a bien reçu mais voilà
il a fondé voilà mes mais parce que
j'aime mon métier j'en ai marre on
écoute une minorité de gens qui ne
comprennent rien forcément ça leur
laisse le monde à voir ce qu'en pensent
les téléspectateurs domino et ça va le
démago à mort la vidéo c'est bon c'est
bon merci oui mais j'aimerais qu'on voit
quand elle se couche sur moi et de
revenir demain
aucune 20% il faut interdire mais bien
sûr vous avez ces sociétés de l'unique
avec ceux qui sont derrière leur écran
et qui n'arrêtent pas à la kasbah où les
jours la preuve du contraire l'ancien
chapiteau plein au cirque losana une
jeune un jour pour venir voir de larmes
aux yeux